Літній туристичний сезон у розпалі.
Через головні повітряні ворота України - аеропорт "Бориспіль" -
лише в червні щодня проходили понад 54000 пасажирів,
що на 30% більше, ніж за перший літній місяць минулоріч.
Попри ажіотаж з відпустками великих черг біля реєстрації немає:
пройти до зони вильоту вже давно можна різними шляхами.
Деякі рейси затримуються, але в аеропорту є розваги і для дорослих
І для дітей – яким і нудьгувати нема часу.
Міжнародний аеропорт "Бориспіль", за рейтингами,
приміром, Sky Tracks є третім найкращим у Східній Європі
І це пасажири здебільшого відчувають.
Все добре. Нас все влаштовує.
Жодних затримок рейсів немає - все добре.
У порівнянні з іншими аеропортами, то ми досить на високому рівні.
Є можливості для того, щоб прийняти закордонних відвідувачів.
Як-то кажуть російською мовою: Не ударить в грязь лицом.
Сервіс? Як було, так і залишилося.
Може, навіть, гірше.
Люди не хочуть працювати, бо ім мало платять.
В принципі, на одному рівні - те ж саме, що і в інших європейських країнах.
Мені з Азією легше порівняти.
Азіатським ми поступаємося, а з європейськими
Бориспіль в принципі можна порівняти.
Міжнародний аеропорт Бориспіль - державне підприємство, яке,
за даними уряду, є одним з найуспішніших в країні.
Водночас саме тому, що Борисполем керують чиновники,
головне летовище країни роками критикують -
як за монополізм на ринку наземного обслуговування та корупцію,
так і за великі проблеми з пунктуальністю рейсів.
Хоча за останні п"ять років ситуація відчутно стала кращою.
І теперішнє керівництво Борисполя заявляє, що весь
чистий прибуток за минулий рік - а це приблизно два мільярди гривень-
повністю пішов на програми розвитку.
Справді усюди сучасна техніка, а поблизу терміналу D
розширюють перон для додаткових виходів до літаків.
Цьогоріч в Борисполі відбулося багато змін.
На цей багаторівневий мегапаркінг пасажири чекали 9 років.
Аеропорт не витримав постійних зривів терміну здачі генпідрядником,
розірвав з ним договір, нарешті, його добудував сам.
В березні почали експлуатацію термінала F, який
після Євро 2012 попрацював усього три роки
і згодом був законсервований.
До літака пішки. Це пасажири лоукостерів.
Термінал F тепер функціонує саме для них.
Це стало можливим фактично після набуття безвізового режиму з ЄС.
Відтоді тільки в одному Бориспольському аеропорту
кількість пасажирів щороку збільшується на 2 мільйони.
Зокрема завдяки збільшенню транзитних рейсів через Київ.
За даними аеропорту, в2018-му тут прийняли майже
12 млн пасажирів, цьогоріч очікують 14-ть млн.
Зокрема, за рахунок зростання кількості рейсів лоукостерів з терміналу F.
Коли ми відкривали термінал F, наше завдання було
забезпечити 10-15 рейсів щодоби.
Наразі вже 20-22, це говорить про його абсолютну ефективність
Вітчизняна авіакомпаніяSkyUpстала першою,
яка переїхала з Жулян в бориспільський термінал F.
Його директор Євгеній Хайнацький розповідає - таке рішення
ухвалили неочікувано, і спершу воно здавалося ризикованим кроком.
Нам деякі маршрути нам треба було трошки змінити за розкладом.
Але ці всі питання наразі урегульовані.
Так сталося, що перон терміналу F наразі більше готовий
до  рейсів до країн ЄС і світу, ніж сам термінал.
УSkyUpнарікають - на вкрай обмежений сервіс для пасажирів.
Там ще немаєdutyfree, немає банків,
до яких вже звикли в терміналі D користуватися пасажири.
Це не від аеропорту залежить, а від
Фонду держмайна, який є розпорядником.
Перемовини з орендарями фонд Держмайна поки не завершив.
Авіаперевізники і керівництво аеропорту нарікають,
що урядові інстанції могли б більше зробити
для розвитку якісних авіаперевезень.
Як-от змінити законодавство, щоб знизити авіа-тарифи
та скасувати акциз на авіаційне паливо, що дасть
головне для пасажирів – зменшить вартість авіаквитків.
Це сприятиме зростанню потоку пасажирів не лише
в бік того ж ЄС, а в і Україну з ЄС.
Таке наприклад, трапляється раз на рік, коли
переповнені літаки з хасидами прилітають до Умані
зустріти там єврейський новий рік.
Проте не може ж Умань залишатся єдиним
масовим туристичним маршрутом в Україну.
Ми вважаємо, що це дещо несправедливо для такої
багатої історією держави, як Україна.
Я вважаю, що в Україні просто немає концепції
розвитку туризму внутрішнього, як це зробили
свого часу Туреччина та Грузія.
Вони мають на сьогодні великий відсоток ввізного туризму.
В Борисполі можна побачити рекламу онлайн-ставок на спорт
або щонайбільше - мобільних операторів.
Проте жодної реклами туристичних переваг, бізнес-можливостей
або культурних подій в українських містах та областях.
Єдиний інформаційний месидж наразі такий -
іноземцям розповідають про російську агресію
на Донбасі і про те, що Крим - це Україна.
Керівництво аеропорту вважає, що туристичний креатив
має йти від уряду та регіональних чиновників.
І запевняє, що головні авіаційні ворота України
можуть щороку приймати до 20 мільйонів пасажирів.
Тобто на 40% більше, ніж зараз.